70 meiner kundschaft ist unter 6 das
problem war einfach gewesen in baden
württemberg in die test ganz die
testpflicht um das sechsjährige aber in
rheinland-pfalz und in hessen war es
nicht so und da meine kundschaft von
überall her kommt war es ein echtes
problem
im mai war so gewesen dass ich teilweise
in der woche zwei tage geschlossen also
über ein
die eltern sagten warum müssen mag ihn
dann noch mal getestet werden wenn sie
schon für die kitas getestet werden
gesetzen ja nur die hälfte unserer
plätze viele waren ja trotzdem sehr
vorsichtig wie gesagt die umsätze also
haben wir nicht auf keinen fall kommen
wir da ran brauck linkshänder ähnlich
den verlust gegen ihr sowieso hat da
kommen wir sowieso nicht dran
erst war der lockte an dann kam die
testpflicht und mit der test nicht gegen
unsere umsätze in den keller
und zwar deswegen die kunden hatten
keine lust auf tests und sind einfach
nicht gekommen sie haben alle ihre
termine abgesagt